yeah she really isn't to beauty she
loves she loves hair looks
that's her thing and she loves a little
bit of makeup that was kim kardashian
back in 2018
talking about her daughter north's love
of makeup
and it seems like the now
seven-year-old's passion has
only gotten stronger she's really aware
of makeup
on sunday the kkw beauty founder took to
instagram to post
this pic of northeast sporting an
unusual makeup look
alongside the caption quote my creative
baby
kim added that north was testing out
some makeup looks that she thinks her
mom should use
on her upcoming shoots and kim says
north even got into some special effects
makeup
using tissue on her cheek covered in
foundation to look like a scar
the 40 year old proud mom of four
wrapped up her post writing quote
i love seeing the looks she creates it's
always so much fun
and two of kim's celebrity makeup artist
pals ash k
holm and joyce binelli hit up the
comments to praise north's work
ash calling it genius joyce within all
caps
i love her i love that back in 2018
kim opened up to e.t about why she lets
her daughter experiment with makeup
you know i i feel like my parents were a
little bit more strict on me wearing
makeup at that age i had more play
makeup that didn't really work
so as long as we keep everything clean
and don't make too much too much of a
mess on things
i am fine with her expressing herself
and having fun with it it's not like
we're going out
and you know she wants a full face of
makeup i mean it's just at home
and playing and honestly the process of
coming up with
an eyeshadow palette and or you know my
loose pigments my flashing lights
collection there's so many
um samples that come before the final
one so i don't like to waste all the
samples so i just give them to her and
then she can play around with it
but north wasn't the only west kid to
make an appearance on their famous mom's
instagram over the weekend
kim also posted lots of pics of north
and her three siblings
saint chicago and psalm it's so
important to give
the perfect amount of attention to every
kid
the skim's founder has been getting in
lots of quality time with her kiddos
after filing for divorce from kanye west
back in february
the keeping up with the kardashians star
is currently seeking
joint and legal custody of the couple's
four children
a source previously told et quote at the
end of the day
kanye and kim love each other immensely
but knew it was time to call it quits
their children are their number one
priority and no matter what
will maintain a positive relationship
for them
[Music]
you